what's a belief nation we are coming to
Dallas for New Year's and we want to
celebrate part of it with you guys so I
made a decision to surprise Dena and
take her to Dallas for New Year's
because we've never been to Dallas a lot
of my fans are in Dallas so the people
who bought my first book are in Dallas
and neither of us have been and is a
direct flight from Toronto so we're
coming in to celebrate New Year's we
arrive late night late late night on the
29th and then we're there and we fly out
the morning of the first we have a whole
bunch of fun activities planned from
cowboy dancing and steak houses and yeah
well it's not quite line dancing but
cowboy dancing and other things that
Nina's not supposed to know about yet
and one of the things we love doing when
Assoc when I travel is meet up with
friends now Nina doesn't usually meet up
with fans with me but she did for the
first time in Atlanta when do we go to
Atlanta a couple months ago we went to
Atlanta and Nina joined it joined in for
the fan meetup appreciation coffee shop
event and what you think your fun
different for you it's always great
having friends show up and see how much
people love her husband anyway we're
coming to Dallas and for those of you
who are in Dallas we want to meet you
we want to have some fun take some
pictures answer questions have some
coffee there's not a lot of time to do
this because we're on a pretty tight
schedule in and out but here's the plan
we're going to meet at the Cafe Brazil
on Saturday the 30th where's Caffrey
Brazil hold on copy Brazil we're gonna
link up the location Cafe Brazil started
the 30th at 9:00 a.m. we're gonna meet 9
a.m. until about 10:30 then we've got to
go off to something else that's the only
window that we have on our trip open so
we're gonna use it for you guys 9:00
a.m. for those of you in Dallas Cafe
Brazil they're famous to be a late-night
place but they're open 24 hours
and Dean is going like this they have
free unlimited coffee refills so Nina's
gonna become a big coffee drinker at the
cafe Brazil maybe before we go on with
the rest of our day so Nina discovered
salted caramel Bailey's and now wants to
add it to every single drink that we
have so what one of my gifts are
Christmas so we have coffee with salted
caramel Bailey's we have green tea with
salted caramel Bailey's lemon juice with
salted caramel Bailey's eggnog we
haven't tried that yet thank not with
salted caramel Bailey's tonight we're
gonna try some eggnog with salted
caramel Bailey's no no oh maybe not okay
okay maybe I won't anyway
Dallas 9 a.m. Saturday the 30th Cafe
Brazil details below for anybody who's
coming leave us a message in the
comments below
and if for whatever reason something
happens we get delay that there's some
change of schedule pay attention to the
comments of this video I'm assuming
everything's gonna go ok but just in
case you know you guys check the
comments and we'll leave updates there
if anything goes wrong but I'm not
anticipating if you going wrong cuz when
Evan sticks to a plan when he makes a
plan pretty much happens so hopefully
we'll see you guys there and for those
of you who are not in Dallas come to
Dallas it's a great city
meet us up January No December 30th and
if you're not gonna come to Dallas to be
with us hopefully you have a fantastic
New Year's and maybe we'll come to your
city next time so thank you guys so much
for watching have a great weekend we're
about to uh well I guess this goes live
Friday so we're hopping a plane tonight
to head to Dallas and have some fun
we'll see you soon
continue to believe and whatever
much love but by Dallas here we come
what's it you just burped I did not burp
that was Annina first full onion affair
okay we love Nina
we love Nina so much Nina
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people need passion and not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's suppose
to mean I don't ever give up I'd have to
be dead or absolutely in faster hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten Rose a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details